RUSSIANS POSE A THREAT TO THE
VERY BASIS OF OUR POLITICAL
SYSTEM.
>> Laura: MICHAEL.
DO YOU SEE A PATTERN HERE?
FORMER OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIAL JUSTIFYING SPYING ON,
SURVEILLING, WHATEVER YOU WANT
TO CALL IT, PUTTING THEM ALL IN
ON AN OPPOSING CAMPAIGN IN A
HOTLY CONTESTED ELECTION, FINAL
THOUGHT.
>> YOU HAVE SPENT TIME IN
RUSSIA, CARTER AND I BOTH HAVE.
IN RUSSIA THEY CALL THIS THE
NATIONAL SECURITY LEADERSHIP
THAT SECRETLY SPIES ON THE
CITIZENRY OF RUSSIA AND HERE WE
ARE IN THE UNITED STATES WITH
OUR OWN UNDERNEATH
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING THAT I
KNOW FOR A FACT.
THIS INFORMANT, THIS PERSON THAT
THEY PLANTED, TRY TO PLANT INTO
THE CAMPAIGN AND EVEN INTO THE
ADMINISTRATION IF YOU BELIEVE
AXIOS, HE'S NOT THE ONLY PERSON
THAT CAME AT THE CAMPAIGN AND
THE FBI IS NOT THE ONLY OBAMA
AGENCY THAT CAME AT THE
CAMPAIGN.
I KNOW BECAUSE THEY CAME AT ME
AND I'M LOOKING FOR CLEARANCE
FROM MY ATTORNEY TO REVEAL THIS
TO THE PUBLIC.
THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING.
AND I WILL TELL YOU, WHEN WE
FINALLY FIND OUT THE TRUTH ABOUT